che carino benvenuti saint maurice
oggi il nuovissimo bisogno degli scherzi
anno maestra ormai è diventato il nostro
gioco preferito voi piace tantissimo
ogni giorno ci chiedete di fare altri
scherzi altri livelli che non avete
visto lo scorso video in cui facciamo
dispersi alla maestra con lo slime nella
vasca domanda andate a vederlo dopo
questo video è anche vitale sta facendo
certi nel suo canale alla maestra in di
andata dove vanno a iscrivervi al suo
canale se non siete ancora iscritti oggi
le faremo degli scherzi particolarmente
cattivi e divertenti essi sarà
nuovamente il fidanzato di spiriti il
doppio più divertenti sempre lasciate un
bel mi piace se volete vedere altri
episodi degli scherzi alla maestra
ricordatevi di seguirmi su instagram
posto non mi seguite anche su tik tok
mettetevi comodi prendere i pop corn
iniziative dorico scherzo allora skatea
0 vuole dimagrire scivola un po correre
se il personaggio maschio perché sta
giocando vitale al tapis roulant
che dice miss universo miss universo che
ha detto miss mondo 2020 il libro dica
stava correndo nel tapis roulant e
dicevamo smettere di correre perché devo
diventare messo universo ma il modulo
2020 e in più davanti al tapis roulant a
una foto di sé tipo con la fascia miss
universo tutta photoshoppata dobbiamo
fare in questo livello questo scherzo
dobbiamo manomettere il tapis roulant
sarà trasparente così magari la facciamo
cadere o la facciamo correre tra faceva
orrore ii fu sicuramente sta già
attrezzando
prendiamo un po di cose qua di andré
penso che sarà molto divertente questo
scare alla mini del video scriveteci nei
commenti quale è stato lo scherzo che vi
è piaciuto più di tutti quello che vi ha
fatto più ridere anche noi vi diremo il
sito preferito perché non si aprono
perché manuale perché quando aprite le
porte e fatto rumore lei center il
cacciavite
ricordatevi anche voi di guardare sempre
le camere di sicurezza lei sta
avvicinando sgabuzzino trovare la porta
è stato molto cemento in treno che li si
sta specchiando nel bagno quindi abbiamo
il tempo di salire su dobbiamo trovare
la stanza in cui c'è santacroce tapis
roulant scelgo sta giungendo ligua al
piano di sopra pd aperto
[Applauso]
messa la paventata abbiamo di farci da
questa volta no fai piano quando lanci
riforme ma capitoline losca puzzino
sotto ok sta salendo su nessun ancora no
non mi ricordo una stanza ecco la guerra
c'è un foglio qua c'è scritto al manuale
verde ma ci sono i vari cavi dobbiamo
decidere quale cavo tagliare i orgoglio
il rosso e che cosa era in rosso invece
perché non tagli anche quello speed down
così cioè quello che rallenta qual'era
non me le proprio tagliare però immagino
che questo è uno di quegli scherzi che
cambiano in base alla decisione che fai
quindi in base al periodo che decide di
tagliare cambia la reazione è ovvio
oggi è andata sul tetto no non è fallito
uno scherzo rollier riuscita comunque a
fermarsi qui forse perché ha ridotto la
della città dobbiamo tagliare due fili o
forse tutti i fili per mare riproviamo
ok ragazzi ci risiamo abbiamo ripetuto
il livello questa volta vitale ha preso
due pinze perché forse il trucco quello
usare due pinze per tagliare due cavi
vediamo se funziona
tagliamo prima in rosso che era lo stop
ehi e l'altro collega era il giallo
motiverebbero ricordate voler vedere il
manuale lì per fortuna e tipo bloccata
no allora rosso stop speed down nel
verde ok tagli a rossano erano e rossano
tagliato ho detto devo tagliare il verde
spidla un ok da un vuol dire rallentare
quindi tagliamo il filo che la rallenta
e così li non potrà fermarsi perché è
forse perché queste non avevano la
protezione di plastica e quindi ci siamo
folgorati dobbiamo prendere quelle rosse
alla produzione né almeno se anche voi
fate questi libri imparerete dai nostri
errori e costa affidati a fare cosa non
bisogna fare ok abbiamo preso l'altra
pinzate con la pratica che qua fuori nel
tavolo in giardino che i ragazzi ci
risiamo questa volta vita la presa due
pinze con la bruttina saremo né in
plastica speriamo di riuscirci questa
volta vediamo allora rosso e verde rai
bravo bravo
c'è scritto assicurati che non sembri
che non sembri appunto che noi abbiamo
messo le mani nel tapis roulant abbiamo
paura dobbiamo solo aspettare che lui
vada mentana era super divertente che
non si fermò fi che è volato ma i
momenti che mi fissava costituirà va
avanti
erano un po inquietanti carta nissim
prossimo scherzo che ri teacher a un
nuovo motto che dice mantieni la calma e
mantenere calma e prenditi cura di te
come se fosse alla spa qualcosa del
genere è arrivato il momento di
insegnarle una lezione la sua statua
fidanzato che sta costruendo
anche capire che si sta facendo
costruire la statua in giardino dal
fidanzato e anche detto mi prendo gioco
di te e poi ha detto è arrivato il
momento di un po di del kers che vuol
dire un po di cura di senza umana vuole
un pò rilassarti non so se vuole fare un
bagno una maschera per il viso
comunque non è quello che dobbiamo fare
è trovare qualcosa per prendere il
cemento è velocissimo ha preso aiuto
abbiamo fatto a vederci dalla giu non lo
so che ci sto provando
no è mancato poco per avere benissimo
allora mitel ha preso una ciotola per
prendere il cemento fare questa giornata
ti vede era fidanzato allora questo che
cos'è che no non è questo è il cemento e
qua dentro
devo solo fermare non raggiunge il
cemento alla sotto la vita
[Musica]
molto bene prendiamo la ciotola e quindi
dobbiamo anche stare attenti al
fidanzato si è notato che il momento
giusto
troviamo però solo lascia minuto prima
che arriva a chi
ok senza scaricare la sotto una dobbiamo
scappare da per lui legali ma non vedo
più la luminaria due persone sono
riusciti a prenderlo bene siamo riusciti
attento che lei in giardino ok ora
dobbiamo mettere la ciotola di cemento
immagino in bagno perché lei ha detto
che vuole un po di spa un po di selfcare
così magari confonderà il cemento con un
cartello per il viso
questo è uno scherzo cattivello sta
entrando subito il botto ti avviso
quando sale sopra sta già andando in
bagno
no in cucina ma che guadagno no non è
questo
non è questo perché lì a due quindi
dobbiamo trovare il bagno ecco bravo hai
coraggio tutto ok ok piuttosto parlare
abbiamo sostituito una sua ciotola in
cui c'era forse una maschera per il viso
o qualcosa del genere con la ciotola di
cemento e ora dobbiamo fare ma che mai
ha proprio nella finestra attento
fidanzato
[Musica]
[Applauso]
sabato prossimo scherzo sembra che
scheri teacher non rimbalzerà c'è non
rimbalzerà ritornando indietro da questo
disastro scusatelo 38 molto male ancora
cercando di dimagrire vuole provare per
una modella
[Musica]
allora innanzitutto lo abbiamo visto che
si allenava alla velocità della luce
partita come abbiamo visto prima le
vuole diventare una modella anzi non una
modella una miss universo non miss mondo
ma questo universo
comunque siccome si è accorta che noi li
abbiamo manomesse st p roulant ammesso
nella porta un lettore di impronte
digitali quindi si può entrare ora nella
stanza nella sua palestra solo con la
sua impronta digitale
quindi c'è scritto usa un trucchetto da
spia per riuscire a superare il lettore
di impronte digitali tagliamo un dito lo
ha ammesso lo sbaglio di fini non
possiamo entrare nella palestra sta
diventando sempre più furba scheri
teacher infatti sta diventando sempre
più difficile farne gli scherzi ma
riusciremo a farle anche questo scherzo
e allora che cosa potremmo prendere per
bypassare le impronte digitali lena in
mente lo scotch a per copiare l'impresa
statale dove potrebbe aver messo
liquidità sta in cucina
qui abbiamo della colla
la cava non è sempre utile non solo per
lo slide a schermo piano di sopra
no si sia per qualità stai attento ok
dall'altra parte poi scendere giù la
testa perché può trovare le sue impronte
digitali ma anche lo scotch per
prenderle punto speriamo solo che lì non
ci scopre se si scoprono tiriamo una
cosa in testa
ok tanto legno ancora piano di sopra si
sa si sta girando la nostra scendendo
giù in cucina ci dobbiamo sbrigare la
borraccia con l'acqua dove aveva bevuto
prima non era il caso
quando avere la palestra quindi vita mia
con di atene tornando al meno male ha
copiato le sue impronte digitali dalla
bottiglia d'acqua da questa va bevendo
con lo scotch e adesso che abbiamo ad
essere impronti digitali
dovremmo essere in grado di entrare
nella palestra non mi ricordo della
palestra tutti i ricordi ancora gioco
controllo eccola che proviamo a
funzionare
ora devo mettere una colla li sta già
salendo a cacciare dopo ok abbiamo tolto
le prove così le noci
la scoperta io non lo so come un fatto
c'è mancato pochissimo perché se non
continuando a ribaltare sue parole lo
scherzo allora scrittice ruolo a vuole
fare tipo alla cat walk come le modelle
quindi nella sorella
diamole una gentile spinga la direzione
a non me la faremo cadere
vediamo cosa sta guardando le sfilate
[Musica]
che buffon inciampando
allora lei ha detto mi esce mi viene
così naturale camminare così nera nella
pastella come le modelle magari dove
dovrei chiamare francis princes e il suo
fidanzato
quello che abbiamo visto negli altri
scherzi e dovrei fargli vedere quanto
sei brava sono un ottimo capire per
farli un bello scherzetto è farla cadere
o qualcosa del genere ma un modo per
rovinarle la camminata nella passerella
da modella vediamo un indizio c'è un
fritto di trovare il capo ma ci si deve
trovare un cavo per farla inciampare
vediamo segua il cavo per farla
inciampare
vediamo che cosa c'è una bottiglia olio
oli voi lavoriate viva per farla
scivolare ancora non abbiamo però
trovato il filo per farla poi cadere
eccolo perfetto abbiamo trovato il filo
per farla cadere l'olio e ora mancherà
qualcosa
secondo me manca ancora qualcosa per
farla cadere o scivolare a fasi fasi
plastica
un po come di petali di rosa sicuramente
la rovina per lei per fare la sua
bellissima passerelle entrando sta
entrando qui
o forse meglio a marco vederci dopo
dobbiamo posizionare tutto nelle scale
c'è scritto di mettere il filo delle
scale cosiddetti che cadrà vediamo dove
sta andando forse sta andando a vedere
la tv ha sentito si è fermata per un
momento sta tornando indietro già
sentito vediamo dove va ma se sta
uscendo fuori
speriamo così almeno possiamo agire
indisturbati sì non andò fuori e baio
data forio che andiamo a piazzare la
trappola delle scale poi integrali ma
casa vanoli all'olio dobbiamo fare
adesso
scappa scappa scappa scappa stampa così
lei mostra sprazzi avrà francis e non
vede l'ora di vedere la sorella tra chi
sta dando stato le scale
[Musica]
lo slow mo assoluto del bellissimo
abbiamo anche visto dal suo punto di
vista mentale che ha fatto bene per 3 1
gli scherzi in cui scheri tizio si crede
una moderna sarà cambiato idea
lo scopriremo nei prossimi schermata
rovinosa sono invece nei commenti quale
ruota il vostro scherzo preferito per me
quello delle palle che loro chiamano
nell'aria nel genere
anche per questo delle scale per me ma
divertente scrivete il vostro preferire
lasciate un bel mi piace e ora vi
lasciamo 4 casellina wikitude cliccare
promette altri media cade su quella che
preferite
[Musica]
[Applauso]